AS SIGNS OF PROGRESS, OF COURSE,
IN A SEA OF CHALLENGES.
>> ALL RIGHT, JEFF ZELENY,
THANKS SO MUCH.
LET'S DIG DEEPER INTO THE NEW
POLL NUMBERS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
JUST A LOW APPROVAL RATING.
NUMBERS SHOW MANY AMERICANS
SHARE A SOMBER OUTLOOK ON THE
STATE OF OUR NATION.
LET'S BRING IN DAVID CHALIAN TO
HELP US BREAK IT DOWN.
WHAT'S THE MOOD OF THE UNITED
STATES RIGHT NOW?
>> YEAH, SOMBER IS A GOOD WORD,
JAKE.
SOUR, TOTALLY DISAPPOINTED,
DISGRUNTLED.
ANY OF THOSE WORDS GETS AT HOW
BAD AMERICANS PERCEIVE THE STATE
OF THINGS RIGHT NOW.
HOW WELL ARE THINGS GOING IN THE
COUNTRY TODAY?
ONLY 21% SAY THINGS ARE GOING
WELL.
I WANT TO PUT THAT IN SOME
HISTORICAL CONTEXT FOR YOU.
21% IS THE LOW POINT.
THIS GOES BACK IN FACT OFF THIS
CHART, JAKE, YOU HAVE TO GO BACK
TO 2009 TO FIND A TIME WHEN THE
AMERICAN ELECTORATE WAS THIS
DISSATISFIED WITH THE WAY THINGS
WERE GOING IN THE COUNTRY.
AND WHEN WE ASK SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT ECONOMIC CONDITIONS AND WE
SAY CAN YOU RATE THE ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS TODAY, LOOK AT THIS
NUMBER.
82% OF RESPONDENTS IN THIS POLL
SAY ECONOMIC CONDITIONS IN
AMERICA ARE POOR.
ONLY 18% SAY THAT ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS ARE GOOD RIGHT NOW,
JAKE.
>> DAVID, HOW DO AMERICANS THINK
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS HANDLING THE
COUNTRY AND SPECIFICALLY THESE
ECONOMIC CONCERNS?
>> WELL, YOU SHOWED HIS OVERALL
JOB APPROVAL RATING EARLIER.
HERE IT IS AGAIN.
38% APPROVE.
62% DISAPPROVE.
THIS IS A NUMERIC LOW MARK FOR
THE PRESIDENT IN CNN POLLING.
BUT HE'S BEEN IN THIS LOW RANGE,
WHICH IS A BIG WARNING SIGN, OF
COURSE, FOR HIS PARTY.
BUT I WOULD ALSO NOTE,
REPUBLICANS AND INDEPENDENTS
HAVE STAYED PRETTY CONSISTENT.
ONE OF THE REASONS HIS NUMBERS
HAVE GONE DOWN A BIT IS BECAUSE
HE'S LOSING SUPPORT AMONG FELLOW
DEMOCRATS.
THEN WE ASK HOW IS HE DOING ON A
SERIES AOF ISSUES.
46% ON UKRAINE.
39% ON IMMIGRATION, BUT TAKE A
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS HERE.
ON THE ECONOMY, HE'S AT 30%
APPROVAL.
BELOW HIS OVERALL APPROVAL, AND
ON INFLATION, ONLY 25% OF
RESPONDENTS APPROVE OF HOW THE
PRESIDENT IS TACKLING WHAT IS
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUE BY FAR,
PEOPLE SAY, IN TERMS OF HOW THE
ECONOMY IS IMPACTING THEIR
FAMILY.
>> HOW IS BIDEN DOING COMPARED
TO HIS PREDECESSORS?
>> ONE WAY WE LOOK AT THAT,
JAKE, WE ASK FOLKS, DO YOU
BELIEVE JOE BIDEN HAS THE RIGHT
PRIORITIES?
OKAY, SO RIGHT NOW, ONLY 31% SAY
YES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS THE RIGHT
PRIORITIES.
68% SAY NO.
THIS IS UP TEN POINTS SINCE WE
SCORED THIS LAST YEAR IN THE
BIDEN PRESIDENCY.
SO NOW LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT HOW
THAT 31% WHO SAY YES, HE HAS THE
RIGHT PRIORITIES, STACKS UP
AGAINST HIS MODERN ERA
PREDECESSORS.
LOOK AT THAT.
NOT VERY WELL.
31% FOR BIDEN IS CLEARLY THE LOW
WATER MARK OF ALL TRUMP, OBAMA,
BUSH, AND CLINTON ON THIS SCORE.
>> SHOCKING.
DAVID CHALIAN, THANKS SO MUCH.
LET'S BRIN IN CNN BUSINESS
CORRESPONDENT RAHEL SOLOMON AND
THE NATIONAL CORRESPONDENT FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST," PHILIP
BUMP.
THOSE NUMBERS SHOW AMERICANS ARE
VERY CONCERNED.
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE ECONOMY
AND INFLATION.
ARE THOSE CONCERNS JUSTIFIED?
>> I THINK AMERICANS ARE LOSING
FAITH AND LOSING CONFIDENCE ON
WHEN THIS GETS BETTER, ON WHEN
INFLATION GETS BETTER.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT FOOD
INFLATION AND GAS INFLATION,
BECAUSE THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE STORY.
BUT INFLATION IS SPREADING, WE
KNOW THAT FROM THE LAST CPI
REPORT.
SHELTER INFLATION, RENT
INFLATION INCREASE, .8% IN THE
MONTH OF JUNE, AND 5.8% ON THE
YEAR.
THAT'S THE FASTEST INCREASE
SINCE 1986.
IT'S PERHAPS UNDERSTANDABLY HARD
TO FEEL GREAT ABOUT THE STATE OF
THE ECONOMY WHEN PRICE PRESSURES
ARE SO ELEVATED.
THAT SAID, THE JOB MARKET IS
VERY STRONG.
3.6% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
ALSO STRONG DEMAND FOR WORKERS.
AND WE HAVE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
THE BIG BANKS FROM WALL STREET
TODAY AND LAST WEEK, AND THEY
SAY CONSUMERS ARE STILL SPENDING
AND CONSUMERS STILL LOOK GOOD
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
SO EVEN THOUGH CONSUMERS ARE
STILL SPENDING, IT APPEARS THEY
FEEL LOUSY ABOUT THE ECONOMY.
>> I CAN'T HELP BUT LOOK AT THE
CALENDAR AND NOTICE WE HAVE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS IN NOVEMBER,
AND THIS IS GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT.
>> I'M SKEPTICAL YOU HAD TO LOOK
AT THE CALENDAR TO KNOW THAT,
BUT FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THEY SEE THESE NUMBERS AND THEY
START TO FREAK OUT.
AND TOTALLY JUSTIFIABLY, WHEN WE
LOOK AT HISTORICALLY BETWEEN THE
PATTERN OF THE PRESIDENT'S
APPROVAL AND THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS, THERE'S A STRONG
CONNECTION THERE.
IF JOE BIDEN IS DOING THIS
BADLY, HISTORY SUGGESTS THAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO DO
BADLY IN NOVEMBER AS WELL.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY IS
WE'RE NOT SEEING THE DEMOCRATS
SUFFERING IN WHAT'S CALLS THE
GENERIC DEMOCRATIC BALLOT WHEN
POLLSTERS ASK WHO WOULD YOU VOTE
FOR?
WE'RE NOT SEEING THAT.
THERE'S SOME INDICATIONS IN THE
POLLING THAT BIDEN IS VIEWED
SEPARATELY FROM HIS PARTY AND
DEMOCRATS BROADLY ARE DOING
BETTER THAN IS BIDEN WHO IS
ABSORBING A LOT OF THE
NEGATIVITY THAT AMERICANS ARE
FEELING.
>> ONE THING I ALSO HEAR FROM
POLITICIANS IN BATTLEGROUND
STATES IS, WHATEVER BIDEN IS
DOING NATIONALLY, 38%, TAKE OFF
TEN POINTS FOR HOW HE'S DOING IN
MICHIGAN OR PENNSYLVANIA OR
WISCONSIN BECAUSE THE NATIONAL
NUMBER IS INFLATED BY NEW
YORKERS AND CALIFORNIANS.
SO IT'S EVEN WORSE IN SOME OF
THE BATTLEGROUND STATES.
RAHEL, 75% OF AMERICANS SAY COST
OF LIVING IS THE BIGGEST
ECONOMIC PROBLEM FACING THEIR
FAMILY RIGHT NOW.
IS THERE SOMETHING THAT BIDEN
COULD DO TO COMBAT THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK FIGHTING
INFLATION IS LARGELY THE JOB OF
THE FED.
AND WE HAVE HEARD THE WHITE
HOUSE SAY THEY WILL NOT MEDDLE.
THEY WILL ALLOW THE FED TO
TACKLE INFLATION WITHOUT
INTERFERENCE.
THAT SAID, THERE HAS BEEN A LOT
OF HEAD SCRATCHING ABOUT WHY WE
HAVE NOT HEARD MORE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE IN TERMS OF REMOVING
SOME OF THE TARIFFS ON CHINA.
WE HEARD FROM JANET YELLEN, THE
TREASURY SECRETARY IN EARLY
JUNE, THERE WAS GOING TO BE SOME
RECONFIGURING OF THE TARIFFS IN
THE COMING WEEKS, AND THERE ARE
SOME ESTIMATIONS AND SOME
ESTIMATES THAT REMOVING THE OF
THOSE TARIFFS COULD SHAVE ABOUT
1% OFF CONSUMER INFLATION.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
QUESTIONING AND SCRATCHING THEIR
HEADS BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE
SOMETHING THAT BIDEN COULD
CERTAINLY DO.
IT'S WITHIN HIS TOOL KIT, BUT
WE'RE NOT HEARING THAT YET.
THAT HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WONDERING WHY NOT.
>> I PUSHED THE WHITE HOUSE
ECONOMIC DIRECTOR ON THIS, OR
THE CHAIR OF THE -- A TOP
ECONOMIC AIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ON THIS ISSUE.
MY QUESTION WAS VERY SIMPLE.
IS THE ONLY REASON YOU'RE NOT
GETTING RID OF THESE TARIFFS
WHICH WOULD BRING PRICES DOWN, I
HAVE HEARD AN ESTIMATE OF $500
TO $1,000 PER FAMILY FOR THE
YEAR, IS THE ONLY REASON YOU'RE
NOT GETTING RID OF THEM IS
BECAUSE LABOR UNIONS LIKE THEM,
AND SHE DIDN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
>> ONE OF THE QUESTIONS HERE IS
Y THINK A CORE PROBLEM THAT
BIDEN HAS, PARTICULARLY AMONG
DEMOCRATS IS THIS PERCEPTION OF
A LACK OF WILLINGNESS TO TAKE
ACTION.
NOT ONLY ON INFLATION, NOT ONLY
ON THE ECONOMY, AND NOT ONLY IN
CHALLENGING PARTS OF THE
CONSTITUENCY, BUT GENERALLY
THERE'S A SENSE OF AMERICANS
GENERALLY AND DEMOCRATS THAT
BIDEN SIMPLY ISN'T BITING INTO
THESE THINGS.
HE'S NOT SHOWING TEETH IN DOING
WHAT HE CAN DO.
WE HAVE SEEN SOME EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS RECENTLY, PARTICULARLY
ON GUNS.
WE HAVE SEEN HIM DO SOME THINGS
NOW, BUT THERE'S A SENSE FROM
DEMOCRATS IN PARTICULAR THAT
BIDEN SIMPLY IS LETTING THE
MOMENT PASS BY AND NOT ACTUALLY
ENGAGING IN AN ACTIVE AGENDA.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THE BIDEN
PEOPLE WILL SAY IS, HEY, OIL
PRICES, GAS PRICES ARE GOING
DOWN.
THE AVERAGE PRICE TODAY FOR A
GALLON OF GAS IS $4.52.
STILL A LOT OF MONEY BUT DOWN
FROM $4.68 LAST MONTH, ALMOST
$5, SHOULDN'T THAT GIVE BIDEN A
BIT OF A BUMP?
>> WELL, IF IT SHOULD, IT'S NOT.
WE SEE IT IN THE POLLING.
LAST WEEK WE SAW IT IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN CONSUMER
SENTIMENT.
PEOPLE STILL FEEL VERY LOUSY
ABOUT THE STATE OF THINGS.
AND THAT IS PERHAPS BECAUSE EVEN
IF YOU'RE GETTING SOME RELIEF AT
THE PUMP, YOU'RE NOT GETTING IT
AT THE GROCERY STORE.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING IT IF YOU
SIGN UP FOR A LEASE.
UNTIL AMERICANS FOR SURE START
TO SEE A GLIMMER OF HOPE, A
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL
IN TERMS OF A TURN IN INFLATION,
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
FEEL NEGATIVE BECAUSE THEY HAVE
LOST CONFIDENCE AND FAITH ON
WHEN THIS GETS BETTER AND
HOPEFULLY THE GAS PRICES ARE
REFLECTED IN CP iREPORT NEXT